The "Wonder Woman" series is
reportedly no more – or at least,
it's not going to happen the
way the director meant it to.
"You should be ashamed."
"My apologies."
"Diana."
In the wake of such critical
failures as "Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice" and "Suicide Squad," fans
of DC started to rapidly lose faith in Warner
Bros. Despite being only a few installments
into what was then the DC Extended Universe,
the studio had already demonstrated a worrisome
inability to keep their film quality consistent.
Thankfully, 2017's "Wonder Woman" bucked this
trend by offering moviegoers an engaging,
visually interesting superhero story that critics
and general audiences alike would come to agree
was a triumph for the genre. For a moment, it
seemed like the DCEU was on the right track.
But Warner Bros. failed to maintain consistent
quality across their DC releases post-"Wonder
Woman," and with the sequel, the "Wonder Woman"
series also ran into the issue of quality control.
In 2020, director Patty Jenkins
and Diana Prince actress Gal Gadot
reunited for "Wonder Woman 1984," a period
piece focused on the Amazonian princess set
in the '80s that calls back to the Richard
Donner "Superman" era of comic book films.
Sadly, unlike its predecessor, it
struggled tremendously to win folks over,
as evidenced by numerous poor
reviews and a muted fan reaction.
Even though "Wonder Woman 1984" wound
up becoming something of a misfire,
Warner Bros. at one point still planned to get
the ball rolling on "Wonder Woman 3." Sadly
for those hoping to see the "Wonder Woman"
trilogy completed, plans have since changed.
As revealed on December 7, 2022 by The
Hollywood Reporter, "Wonder Woman 3" is
officially off the table at Warner Bros.
Discovery. According to the publication,
Patty Jenkins recently submitted a treatment she
put together alongside co-writer Geoff Johns,
only for them to find out that the feature
is no longer on DC's release slate.
The reason for this move? DC Studios
heads James Gunn and Peter Safran,
as well as Warner Bros. Pictures'
Michael De Luca and Pamela Abdy,
who all reportedly felt the threequel wouldn't
fit within the studio's new direction.
This announcement comes shortly after Gunn
and Safran were selected to helm DC Studios,
in hopes of keeping DC-related
films and television programs
cohesive and of the highest quality possible.
At the time the THR report was published,
the duo was set to meet with Warner Bros.
Discovery CEO David Zaslav to work out the
specifics of what the DC Universe will
look like under their watchful eyes.
"Wonder Woman 3" now joins the likes of
fellow 2022 cancellations "Batgirl" and "The
Wonder Twins" in the DC media graveyard,
while such productions as "Shazam! Fury
of the Gods," the ever-controversial
"The Flash," and more remain intact.
According to a Deadline report about new DC
heads James Gunn and Peter Safran canceling
"Wonder Woman 3," one anonymous source claimed
that the door is open for director Patty Jenkins
to submit plans for an entirely new "Wonder
Woman" project, despite the cancellation of
her threequel. Seemingly, then, Gunn and Safran
have no issue with Jenkins' work as a filmmaker,
so much as they genuinely seem to be taking
the DC film universe in a brand new direction.
Gal Gadot's future with DC, meanwhile, is
murkier. On December 6, just prior to news
of the "Wonder Woman" cancellation, Gadot
tweeted about her longtime superhero role,
concluding with the promise that she "Can't
wait to share [Diana's] next chapter with you."
But that message came before the news broke that
the planned sequel was no longer moving forward.
Whether or not Gadot might remain a part of
any future Jenkins "Wonder Woman" project,
or even a part the DC cinematic universe moving
forward, is not quite certain for the time being.
Perhaps someday we'll see Patty
Jenkins and Gal Gadot's "Wonder
Woman" trilogy completed,
but for now it's in the bin.